who is making it down the aisle first
you two or court and travis oh cool i'm
not my business i wrote this song for my
wife
it's been six days since the last time i
saw your face megan who turns 36 today
got emotional during mgk's performance
and while reps haven't confirmed or
denied that the twin flames have tied
the knot he's called her his wife before
what he hasn't done before dedicate a
song like this
[Music]
how are you two celebrating your
birthday tomorrow we're going away into
the desert together with no cell phones
is this going to be another ayahuasca
experience too but we did that last year
from my birthday but it is an eclipse so
i'm sure i'll be crying a lot which is
his favorite
my wife was just with me and then she
saw machine gun kelly and i could see
her eyes wander a little bit
oh she's right here steve i'm saying
and you thought she left you do you know
who machine gun kelly is no there we go
okay i'm safe
michael buble and wife louis santa
lopilato showed off baby bump number
four and told us they still can't agree
on a baby name i like amelia like amelia
earhart
but not for me because i don't think
anyone's going to be able to say that
yellow jello they're going to make fun
of them
also making it a date night nominee
miranda lambert with hubby brennan
mclaughlin and heidi klum sharing a kiss
with husband tom countless but single
and looking to mingle jack arlo i see
the whole city from this balcony
is someone here though that you got your
eye on
let me see
there is attention you want to take a
glance at it we've got well miranda
lambert she's married let me read it
don't be trying to give me candidates
i'm trying to play cupid here for you
wonderful iconic people here
[Music]
about the symbol
thank you entertainment tonight i love
and it was a family night for kylie
jenner and travis scott four-year-old
stormy was mom and dad's date at her
first ever award show and she got to
watch travis in his first tv performance
since the astroworld tragedy
less than a minute after travis left the
stage morgan wallin who also faced
controversy and was actually banned from
the show last year won big he took home
top country male artist with his mom by
his side not long after performing his
song about forgiveness
[Music]
how would you say you have grown
in the last year
i think mostly i could attribute it to
being a dad
just seeing that i have another life
that i'm responsible for kind of put
things into perspective for me he went
to his first ever concert it was yours
it was special you know i kind of
dressed him like me and everything we
kind of we did the whole little shebang
diddy tonight
talked about how he wanted you and
travis scott here saying he wanted to
un-cancel the cancelled what do you make
of that you know i've never uh ever
spoke to diddy but i i would like to
tell him thank you tonight so it means a
lot ten years from now we'll still be on
top i'm about to start the show y'all
i'm opening up the show so i gotta get
ready
it was
host diddy had five of his kids there
for support it's 25 years since he won
his first billboard music award he this
is a full circle moment for him that's
crazy i wasn't even born yet
e.t was exclusively backstage and in the
portrait studio with all the stars
including dosha cat still beaming after
she won four golden mics my girl dolce
cat
the moment your name was called you
grabbed your drink you chugged it headed
to the stage what was going through your
mind there's things that i know like i'm
nominated and things like that and like
stay here you might get but my mind is
like oh my god janet jackson was 10 feet
away from me and oh my god mary j blige
has been 10 feet away from me for the
last like how long have we been here i
was shocked and i ran up i was like i
need something it was great it was
amazing
this moment with the cut out the cutouts
hello won't you do it
i'm wearing a big man
i've got like three strips of eyelashes
on each eye i heard you have 30 000
worth of diamonds on your nails uh yeah
i'm going to take these off and turn
them into rings and then we're donating
100 of the proceeds to a cleveland
charity it took 10 hours to apply
machine gun kelly's 11 carat diamond
manicure fiance megan fox in david coma
debuted bangs on the carpet and today's
not only her birthday but janet jackson
turned 56. janet
jackson
the surprise presenter wore a tie and
top hat seemingly a nod to her brother
michael to give mary j blige the icon
award mary stunned in two dresses and
snagged a pair of slippers backstage
janet jackson um
you were always one of our biggest
inspirations growing up how you feeling
wonderful
purple was the color of the night and
host diddy gave us 10 different looks
kylie jenner hit the carpet in belmont
but come on stormy stole the entire show
adorbs in her rick owens dress love
yourself
that's top female rap artist winner
megan the stallion getting a little help
with her poses from cara delevingne
while top r b artist winner doja cat
accessorized with a custom gold saturn
purse hearing shaped like ears and heels
with golden toes you don't have to
polish your toenails it's great i don't
i lost a toenail believe it or not this
this ringtone no it's the middle one
right there
[Music]
you